time to make friends that's what this
robots doing at an annual meeting of
British and Russian businesses it's also
what Russia's new ambassador to the UK
seems to want my mission is of course to
making relations better we do not know
what's going to happen after the
elections we are watching closely what
political parties are saying what kind
of reports are being done we have no
preference in this relations and we are
not at all are trying to influence it it
does make any sense a refusal by Boris
Johnson to publish a report on Russia
has made Moscow a hot topic publish this
report and let us see for ourselves
otherwise there is only one question
what have you got to hide has become
fashionable to accuse us about anything
and everything an intervention which has
nothing at all to do with realities a
reality at this forum is that British
and Russian trade is on the rebound
even as diplomatic ties remain on ice
officials here talk of further growth
after brexit but Britain and its allies
are wary of a country they see as a
threat next week the leaders of NATO are
going to be meeting here in London to
mark the Alliance's 70th anniversary a
number of the member states have voiced
a desire to see relations between Russia
and the Alliance improve what does
Russia want risks which are now
connected to Russia sometimes exaggerate
and quite a lot exaggerate that's why I
think it's a the answer for your
question is definitely yes we want
relations we were
the hope is for Russian and British
trade to saw what's not clear yet is
where the politics and diplomacy will
follow
Deborah Haynes Sky News